so Grace is there anything that I can
proactively do to protect my accounts
absolutely I'm so glad you asked we
recommend that folks use something
called two-step verification now you
have a password to log into your account
but if you are able to turn on two-step
verification that is a second layer of
authentication to verify that you are
you this is extremely helpful in the
event that a password is stolen through
a phishing attempt because even if
someone has access to your password they
won't be able to log into your account
without also having your phone or your
computer Which is far less likely so
two-step verification can mean receiving
a text message to verify that it's you
or an email or even a phone call this is
something we really recommend people do
especially for things like bank accounts
or any any sort of account where you
have a lot of personal information no I
can't tell you how important that is
Grace I use two-step verification on
pretty much any account that I
definitely do not want people to break
into and I have to say over the last
four or five years there's been a few
situations where all of a sudden I got a
text message on my phone saying here's
your security code and I'm like wait I
didn't even ask for a security code it
means someone might have compromised one
of my accounts and is trying to log in
but the two-step verification is
actually keeping them out because the
odds that someone got your password
somehow and has physical possession of
your phone or a computer very very low
unless you have some shady people in
your house or your workplace
that's absolutely right Sal and the fact
that you received that message and
immediately said hey this wasn't me
that's two-step verification working as
intended
another tool that I like to recommend
that folks uses something called the
password manager this can help you keep
track of your passwords and make sure
that you're using strong passwords and
updating them regularly so you can save
your passwords in your browser so
instead of having to keep track of 20
different passwords yourself that tool
does it for you no that that's really
helpful because I think there could be a
strong temptation to put easy passwords
or reuse the same password over and over
again to just make it memorable but that
makes you extra vulnerable so if you use
these things you can have super secure
different passwords for every site
exactly unfortunately many people do
reuse the same password or use it not a
very secure password that might be easy
to guess so we really recommend to move
over to that password manager and then
you only have to remember one password
to that super helpful another tool that
I recommend people look into is
something called security checkup that's
a place where you can actually keep
track of all your online accounts and
passwords and be notified if there is a
breach such as a data breach or a
phishing attempt that got access to your
passport I'll help you keep track of
kind of how long those passwords have
been saying in the same and remind you
to update them so definitely check out
security checkup as well super useful
thanks so much grace
thank you Sal